welcome back to new rock stars news
folks Marvel's Netflix daredevil has
been cancelled has it been canceled it's
more on that to come
it's been canceled the show has been
canceled but it's is daredevil really
leaving the world from us we're also
gonna cover some exciting tidbits about
Toy Story 4 and spider-man into the
spider-verse
and we'll also give you some interesting
trivia about why Queen Elizabeth was not
allowed to sit on the Iron Throne join
me at the table today our Sam bachelor
in Maude Garrett welcome guys let's get
started talking about a daredevil now if
you're partying this weekend make sure
to pour one out for daredevil on Netflix
Netflix officially canceled the show
meaning that the recently released
season 3 will be its last we're not
gonna get any bull's eye costume and oh
Lord Dark Wind I know I know we're all
feeling pretty sad but here's the upside
an official statement from Marvel
included this we look forward to more
adventures with the Man Without Fear in
the future reference like anyone named
Dark Knight Daryl man without fear he's
mainly afraid of a lot of stuff and a
little bit of fear he's afraid of
getting canceled yeah well you should
well he wasn't and that was right
should've been afraid now ok so what
does this mean will they resurrect the
character for Disney Plus I mean that
seems to be the the forces that are
moving things right Disney pluses
Disney's new streaming service is gonna
be a direct competitor with Netflix and
maybe that's why they're they're
bringing the character back home
daredevil did seem to be a hit for
Netflix so he kind of paved the way for
Luke Cage and Jessica Jones and iron
fist The Punisher the defenders team-up
series I'm gonna stop you there that's
why this show doesn't exist anymore
there's an oversaturation happening on
Netflix in the market it's too many
shows flew to 1/2 those shows are fine
yeah but so we'll see it seems like it's
the character itself at least of
daredevil is for sure popular enough to
draw some eyeballs wherever he ends up
and for those of you who were freaking
out Jessica Jones and the Punisher still
have new seasons in the work
the Punishers wrapped its second season
and Jessica Jones third season is
currently in production but it does
sound like those seasons will probably
be the last oh we can get like one last
offenders just to tie the bow on it all
no it's done the CW shows work when they
do their big crossovers is that every
lead is paid exactly the same amount
when they cross over to another show so
I'm gonna guess that that works the same
for all of those shows so I'm guessing
defenders cost a lot and didn't return a
lot of that because they didn't even I
prefer even mentioned that it was
canceled they're just like that's it
we're done it's done and the actors are
pretty you know they seem to be saying
IRA I must be right behind a Grimm on
the set of Jessica Jones right now of
course you're happy to work we just like
we just know that there's a ticking
clock yeah this is the cinematic future
is a thing they might use it whatever
remaining season they have out there to
kind of just you know crazy have some
closure maybe for sure yeah that'd be a
great idea yeah that's an opportunity to
say goodbye no what do you guys think do
you think we're gonna see more daredevil
in the future do you think it will be
Charlie Cox will they reboot recast the
character and do you think maybe this
means the Marvel Cinematic Universe
could be bringing daredevil into the
fold and phase 4 daredevil is now
Marvel's Constantine yeah he landed
somewhere he's doing great how was it
you're like legends I guess it's it's so
weird it's so at this point they fought
a demonic unicorn and it was the best
that was the best episode of television
I've watched in years
but I also wouldn't when they were
talking everyone's kind of speculating
like what was gonna happen they're gonna
make it over the Disney Plus it's like
yeah boy you're not gonna see these
actors they're all they're all
responding in ways of like man I really
love the good old days like that's gonna
be a bummer there was even a writer that
was like yeah we had season four
pictures up on the wall we were in our
writers room and now you just cancelled
mid like pre-pro like okay like is
anything safe like really think outside
of just Marvel and television is
anything safe anymore
just in the world yeah it's
dangerous time to be alive yeah yeah
let's but you know on a lighter note
look at this is like a positive thing as
much as we liked you know the daredevil
show the car Charlie Cox's take on the
character like you know it's kind of
nice to have all the Marvel stuff under
one big tent so that they can appear in
stuff together like you know the
daredevil character would team up with
spider-man II team up with the Avengers
at times he would you know fight some of
the villains he would use you know he
was one of the guys and now we can
really show up just go a couple blocks
from a Hell's Kitchen over up to Queens
and hang out with spider-man
hopefully that'd be great like that's
obviously the move here like they they
just don't they're gonna be a direct
competitor with Disney Plus Netflix will
be and they don't want them to have one
of the most valuable properties but they
just made that call that these shows are
not that old they're three years old
they're four years old tops they just
made this decision and they realize now
they're backing out of it it's so quick
to be like wow we bungled it like you
didn't though they made a successful
property that in now this was the first
show I ever watched on twelve seasons of
television programming though a lot
really when you think about it there's a
lot but oversaturation
yeah yeah I think that's that's yeah and
you can make the argument in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe things aren't over
it's impossible to over saturate but I
think that's why it works for them
because it's part of their business
model whereas the shows on Netflix
Jessica Jones Luke Cage they all worked
it's like one arc you know in their own
world but when you try to team them up
and when you try to like build the
references it didn't work as well he's
just oh where's aria Dawson is also in
this show yeah
I could never really felt that fun to
like point out the way they connect to
each other I mean unless it was really
hard for nerds for characters that
should really know each other hell's
kitchen's three blocks like in a square
it's like you should know more Jesse
Jones and daredevil are basically
neighbors like they should 100% know who
each other is but they don't they don't
talk about it and the way they handled
it was so so strange I will say that I
loved I loved all Mosely shows most of
all yeah we're running up here we're
staying positive
season 2 of dare of iron fist was better
than before and Luke Cage season 2 was
one of my favorite seasons of all day
Joseph what would you rank them though
which one should you watch before they
are no longer existing anyway
daredevil I mean that's the most solid
one out of all yeah watch all three
hundred percent yeah interesting like
dilemma do you think that Netflix can be
pressured to remove these off of their
platforms after a couple years so they
only have less and that's scary
yeah we need to go watch these shows if
you haven't already like because that's
what's scary nowadays with everything
moving to streaming apps blockbuster no
longer exists you can't find DVD
versions of all these things yeah one
day gone the next
yeah so buying a blu-ray full season
they could its away they currently where
Disney Plus maybe daredevil could live
on in the movies or one of it like his
own series but it's just it's a bummer
that we're not gonna see this cast
because they've really built out a
really cool cool world for them for
those characters for sure they have yeah
and you know in case daredevil is gone
for good in the world well we know the
Netflix version is gone let's take this
moment of like remember what was great
about daredevil what are some of our
favorite moments from the past
devil oh my favorite mmm was of course
the melon stomping sound effects used
when a man's head was getting beaten to
a bloody pulp in a car gotta love the
sound design he's probably fine I hope
he's okay yeah hope he's doing well my
cards Wow just decapitate decay
Decapitator from his dekappa from his
hated yeah i mean any hallway fight
scene from there yeah like it's like the
and they did them in other shows too or
they tried to season three I know we
didn't talk about it a lot but they do a
prison riot slash prison breakout in one
take it is 11 minutes and there is not a
cut and you see a full riot happen and
in season 2 there are cuts that they
hide but you get to see daredevil
himself taking this protecting the
Punisher and taking out an entire gang
of bikers and seasoned ones it has more
emotional heart than like a lot of other
scenes in these shows where it's like
he's just trying to get to a kid and
like no one else is gonna get in his way
to get to that kid a little bit well you
know you kind of forget that these shows
I actually have besides iron fist and
defenders they have a really clear
through line like this is the character
he has a disability but he's able to be
this person and it's like it's
from their point of view or with
locators is what it means to be a black
person in New York in a world with
powers like this or for Jessica Jones is
someone who was sexually like abused and
she was raped but also it's looking at a
woman's point of view in this it's just
like there's they had these really cool
like just tent pole like thoughts that
were going into these shows and that's
that's special that's cool yeah I'm
gonna miss like the actors take on these
characters because they have been for
the most part really really great not
just like the main cast but the
supporting roles the villains of these
shows really well cast and it's a shame
because I think for the reboot they're
gonna have to recast them just so people
don't like confuse the world of it but
it's a shame because I think Charlie Cox
is awesome and I think like we'll see
how they're adapted on Disney Plus if it
sounds like Disney Plus it's gonna be a
bit more of a family family-friendly
thing I'm gonna miss the dark depths rip
these shows wintry the level of violence
and the adult themes the the language of
the characters like it was nice to see
that take on a superhero story because
we never see that everything has to hit
four quadrants and everything else and
these these Netflix shows have been able
to go to some extremes that Quidditch
friend of mine was talking about this
and I I think it's a pretty good idea so
this is not my idea but I wanted to
share it Marvel Knights is an imprint
that Marvel has where it takes all
daredevil Luke Cage all the their kids
are more adult and they basically
instead of kalim defenders it's just a
little like an anthology week to check
in and see what like that their dark
corner of the universe is if you want
that for the Disney Plus have to be kind
of cool yeah that's called a hint you
put my name on it well let's let's move
on with with a quick toast to daredevil
thanks for this and thanks for the
cheers and the confusing powers that
never really you know state concern
paling right right on floor on our let's
talk about a trivia question this week
you know how it always works we got our
gift of shame and though it's so
shameful the box is pretty shameful
there
we had someone on it right one of you
has been following us and we're gonna
okay so here's a question this week what
city has daredevil lived in aside from
New York City okay all of our answers
are here and as always we'll reveal the
answer at the end of the episode we'll
see who's right who's wrong the best
answer as decided by your judges way to
do our goodbyes the loser is gonna have
to join the gif of shame but we've got
some other interesting news this week
hell yeah
Toy Story 4 is happening we've got a new
poster for the movie which confirms that
it will take place at a carnival
now we've already met keegan-michael key
and Jordan Peele carnival prize stuffed
animal characters in a recent teaser
trailer which is hilarious I love those
two - those two together yeah
but now we expect woody and the gang are
going to be at the carnival as well we
know that the ending to this movie is
supposed to be very emotional in true
Toy Story fashion and Tom Hanks says
that it will change cinema whoa what
does that even mean it sounds like what
Netflix is trying to do yeah change
cinema maybe you're in it maybe you
happening you think right now yeah and
we also know that when there's a sport
that doesn't believe it's actually a toy
and we're going to be at a carnival so
using this information that we have
together and our deducing factors deem
what happens in this movie any
particularly oh I had the full plot
outlined a prediction lined up all and
spoke it into the home
there's a carnival I don't I don't know
the full movie plot obviously by the
crime the wire the there's toys that you
can win just like you know duckie and
bunny like I don't wanna tease are they
always like turned into toys often those
are left behind or they're just like
toys being waiting to be won like does
that affect their psychology or the way
they look at the world they're a prize
their carny toys so they're a little
dirty yep
you know it's confusing is I for a
second there I had this theory in my
brain where it was like oh no something
doesn't become a toy until like someone
like actually adds love to hugs yeah
it's not true though because we see in
Toy Story 2 when buzz goes to the toy
store and has his mind just exploded
when he sees all the other buzzes they
all wake up good or at least one wakes
up so or unless we just you know what I
don't think Toy Story is trying that
hard to make the world work but like
with 4 key it makes it super confusing
it's just a spork with some glue and
some gray like a googly eyes thank you
blanket on that but like so and he
doesn't want to be alive which let's
let's teach these kids an existential
crisis real early on like that one's
really confusing I I think the main plot
is just trying to figure out what it
means to be a toy and what it means to
be loved and like that's probably where
it's gonna go but then when you dive
deeper and get more confusing as to if
you put your those dumb mustaches on
cars does that mean your car's alive
yeah well why do all those Buzz
Lightyear's have a personality I mean
some kid on that Chinese factory
assembly line is hugging those toys you
know crack down on that Foxconn and kid
should not be working in factories we
should be clear that's the point of view
of everyone with us all right
obviously this movie is talking about
the fact that if you fail in anything at
life then you won't win anything and in
this instance it's you win the toys when
it's a game of skill so if you don't
have the skills to be a winner the toys
will never be free baseball throw yeah
it's like that when I
rent money on you know I'm milk tank you
know that's that's the exact same size
as the ball and you can't actually get
it in there hits it through maybe that's
the thing maybe they're all caged and
they're never supposed to be free what a
nightmare this will be there already
nightmarish there's like four goosebump
books that we set at carnivals after all
there's a checklist of things it's like
you have the ones with the clown faces
you had to put the bowl down you don't
you're not gonna think about carnivals
is New York don't actually have clowns
walking around but the aesthetic is such
that a clown could be there yeah oh just
even more frightening it's like when the
red balloon appears then it it's like we
might not see penny wise but he's around
let's be honest the scariest things at
carnivals are loose screws because when
you're on a ride and all of a sudden you
do a loop-de-loop and uh-oh I got free
prizes what is this popcorn uh that's a
washer that's probably not important
we're at the table I'm gonna pour water
in my face but that's what Philip does
when he's here I didn't want to take
that from this bit well let us know in
the comments below what you think a
carnival poster means but the most
exciting thing that's going to be
happening as we're ending 2018
spider-man into the spider verse comes
out December 14th but we've got a few
exciting updates that'll hopefully tide
you over these next two weeks first up
the Stan Lee cameo this movie is the
first Stan Lee cameo to be released
posthumously and features an animated
version of Stan Lee as a New York City
merchant he offers miles some advice at
a key moment and gives him what helps
him possibly but also we've got some
cool spin-off news a spider women movie
has been announced it's going to be a
vulnerable three generations of women
with spider powers it looks like Phil
Lord and Chris Miller will be involved
which is super exciting makes me very
happy about this and people are thinking
that it will probably
include spider-gwen who will be voiced
by Hailee Steinfeld in into the
spider-verse and I got to see the movie
humblebrag and she's great in it
humblebrag the spider whoa oh no not at
all I am very proud that I got to see
that film is in addition to a sequel
that is already in the works I think
we've got another cinematic universe on
our hands boys and girls very excited
yeah and what are the three that they've
said they've mentioned some of the
characters it might be oh yeah there's a
lot of exciting news for Spider Woman
the initial like the grumbling rumblings
I heard were that Spider Woman the
original Jessica drew who her powers are
so confusing she can fly right no idea
why not a clue and she has like an
electric zap spiders can fly and glide
glide and it's really scary ones can fly
they can fly no I'm mr. alien spiders
comply yeah you don't have flies those
are just all spiders their flight is
[Laughter]
what do you guys want to see where you
guys want to see them take these stories
and which ladies do you want to see in
the spider women movie also Madame web
who's been interpreted a few different
ways in like animated cartoons or comics
she's just an older Spider Woman and
then a Spider Girl as well who can
there's a character named araña who's
really interesting and there is like a
mate a Parker who's just a younger like
child of Peter Parker and Mary Jane so
there's different things you can do also
there's also silk I'm a big fan of silk
yeah weren't they gonna do a silk movie
that's may they pull the plug on it no
no this it's yourself it's in there
weird
yeah I think it's exciting you know like
if you're gonna go in a new direction
that's gonna be different from the MCU
yeah let's let's see what these guys
fight a man seems to be killing it at
the moment I mean it had its absent
flows but the latest Tom Holland
iteration of spider-man's the best we've
seen
I feel the latest video game video game
like he's a frontrunner for game of the
year and I've heard every single person
that watched that movie said it's
probably one of the best movies I've
seen mr. Benham hundred million dollars
so we can't really we can say whatever
we want but money talks
yeah but yeah this movie is I I left
this theater overjoyed it was like look
we're gonna get back and see it again
yeah many times it's a holiday here a
lot of cracks in there Laura Montgomery
and Joaquin de Santos who are both
amazingly talented directors and fight
choreographers for animated features
they worked on Joaquin worked on justly
unlimited but I believe Laura and
Joaquin worked on avatar the last
airbender Peter Korra Legend of Korra
and Voltron for Netflix and all those TV
shows are incredible one of the best
parts about how they direct action is
that they're able to like in animation
you're supposed to be able to do
whatever you want and if you guys watch
like the DC animated movie sometimes
that means like they do everything and
you're like it's too much yeah I can't
see they perfectly know how to capture
it and how to tell it like a compelling
story so Joaquim dos Santos is up to two
possibly direct the sequel and that
makes me very good boy and I'm happy
that one called in - oh yeah and too
fast and too furious spider for oh and
there's the power - and Peter and miles
are doing this on the on the cover
you're welcome thumbnail to see if this
is animated right like if the how
successful is this I think there's
something about animation that allows
you to get the tone just right with
these things and allow it is a comic
book it's like a moving comic book you
know like if you're doing comic book
adaptations let's experiment animated
features right he can that wouldn't it
be cool if they did animated
with like spider hands the cartoon like
what if they did little bit yeah the
tiny one yeah more rubbish style yeah
spectacular spider-man remember
Nickelodeon did that one was that like
2008 something like that Oh min ago oh
whoa whoa Easy's well let us know where
you were a decade ago going to different
people for some of you but yeah let's
know what you want to see from this new
spider-verse the Sony verse and how you
want it to be different from the MCU
version of spider-man because that's
that's great but there's other ways to
skin a spider as you know in Australia
some other news coming out this week
everyone's been talking about the fact
that Queen Elizabeth visited the Game of
Thrones set and was not allowed to sit
on the Iron Throne
why she would want to I'm not sure I
feel like every single geek in this
space in throne you got a photo on and
it's straight on Instagram see it said
it but apparently there's an obscure
rule barring the Queen from sitting on
any foreign throne even if it's
fictional just trip on your way up it
and then just know that's interesting
day yeah there's also a rumor going
around that we could see a rocket and
Groot Disney Plus show Oh perfect yeah
that would be donated it sounds like you
know Bradley Cooper and then over Vin
Diesel also margot robbie has revealed
the official birds of prey title it is
the fantabulous emancipation of one
Harley Quinn hmm was it that's an
official title of the movie it's not the
prey it kind of joke
Gossip Girl 2.0 yeah I'm excited of one
Harley Quinn once again night we've got
a new joke a movie set picks these guys
are pushing it out what there's no
security on these set no I think they're
trying to get what build-up hot set
people actually want from it I'm
enjoying it I'm saying a little too much
yeah well back up a little bit we're
saying with policing the whole thing
together this time though as you can see
Joaquin Phoenix is out of clown makeup
and he's visiting a cemetery probably
because it's a funeral look at that suit
though the color is wearing that oh my
god he looks like his cause playing his
Ron Burgundy and then we've got Julie
Andrews if you don't know she is she was
in The Sound of Music and the original
Mary Poppins and the woman I grew up
falling in love with every single day
she's gonna roll in Aquaman she's gonna
be voicing her rappin paracin herethen a
giant sea monster I believe the trailer
oh you mean that giant see mom in the
movie is saying that she's incredible in
it and I also heard that she declined
being a part of the Mary Poppins reboot
so yeah the fact that they were on that
they were the two things on the table
and she changed she won all being more
fun than the other one good awesome
probably they can't like paid to be in
that movie money to be in that a lot but
he paid to be in the movie oh wow he's
not a chimney sweep so moving up in the
world now it comes time for our new rock
stars news lightning round you guys know
this works
you guys sweet has some great questions
I'm gonna fire the moment co-host if
it's them as quickly and without
hesitation as possible are you guys
ready yes matter yes or no my Tamara
Shin noter which two of us
as a doctor would you want to travel
with Matt Smith's doctor I think he
would yell at me the least
true-true Sam was the last non comic
book you read at least at least four
books I really love your books you're
just looking around
you read that book oh no I know what it
is it's the Maze Runner books I'm sorry
gang ain't nothing to apologize it's
garbage it's garbage but rest or eat
I'll tell ya whatever gets kids reading
away from the picture games kids like me
for me at flava a 15 wants to know what
do you think the adventures for trailer
will be like will it just be a teaser or
more ma'am we're thinking this trailer
so but Twitter gonna come out hopefully
next week hopefully you've seen it by
the time you watch this video I think
it's gonna be very obscure it's gonna
use a lot of context to old stuff it's
just gonna be a pile of dust would that
be of someone going through like the
Empire State Building just like
vacuuming I think we're gonna get like
one cryptic interesting piece of
information that comes at the very end
of the trailer and then the title of it
is going to be the thing that blows our
minds and that piece of information and
that the math that we do I think the
rest of its gonna be like okay just kind
of filler but that one thing's gonna
blow our minds Celeste Bailey wants to
know what's a holiday tradition you do
to get into the festive mood I have a
photo shoot with my dog that is very
nice for me Adrian mayor or 14 wants to
know what Marvel character would you
like to get a Secret Santa gift for and
what would you get them hmm I'd get Matt
Murdock
nutmeg five tenets know what's your
favorite Christmas song
none of them series and the fact no
known and I know it's it's November and
I've been hearing them all the time that
I thought there was a rule that they
couldn't start until did don't do it
don't you do
I think by know you meant let it's no
for Sam what's been you were from Sunday
duck what's been your favorite and early
Christmas gift given a received got a
flash helmet got a flash in a flash
helmet that's yeah and what else about
giving you my Christmas my flash water
bottle much one I don't like anything
but I that one I had paint that fell off
on the inside of it so I couldn't drink
it anymore my paint came off on the
inside when I washed it and the question
for me is for sir master Jamie what's my
best Christmas movie besides die hard
obviously thank you for knowing that is
my favorite country I think we all know
it one two three
we're doing it we're doing a fun holiday
breakdown of home alone 15 second shot
outs where each of us has 15 seconds to
shout out plug ramble about anything in
the world Sam do you got something no I
do tonight actually as we're recording
this right after I'm gonna go see and on
the apocalypse it's getting a limited
release right now so go online and see
if we can find tickets it is I've talked
about it before but it is a Christmas
High School Musical zombie film it's
amazing like the trailers don't even do
it justice because of how good the movie
is I got to see the world premiere and
now I get to see like its first like
release so that's so cool it's such it
just it's gonna be fun it's a fun movie
for the whole family go watch it yeah
sounds great
Ahmad do you have something you want to
okay so while I'm doing this I there's a
new app that actually was made 10 years
ago and I'm still having the blast it's
called dungeons and such well you get
I've been around for that long
yeah this guy made it and it's like yay
he started it from 2009 it's really
really cool like a D&D inspired kind of
game but the gameplay and it's amazing
and he keeps updating it as well and I'm
been talking to him on the Facebook page
dungeons and such everyone goes and
download that game immediately on Apple
that's mine and it's getting me inspired
for functions and flagons because
episode 6 is coming in check that out um
and for my 15 seconds to things real
quick of pokemon facts on twitter it's
my new favorite twitter account it's
super funny and then a second the movie
widows it's it's starting to be lit
Davis and directed by Steve McQueen it's
it's like a great crime caper
it's like heat but with widows it's so
fun it's imagine being in the conference
room when that pitch goes down it's like
heat but just sounds like horny women is
so funny it's funny it's fun it's like
gripping and it's got like a good
message it's awesome good yeah okay so
now we're gonna move on to our trivia
answer
remember the question we asked earlier
what other city in the world
daredevil live in the the worst answer
is gonna have to answer our gif of shame
and and here's what we said so mod said
Chicago that derivatives in Chicago Eric
said Rome which is wrong it's a city and
it makes sense because of his name Sam
said hell story that's ridiculous
yeah I know he's Catholic but the good
answer is San Francisco oh I read a
comic where he lived there just living
live in Lidl what did you say
geographically my how many wait someone
do the math how far away's the center of
the earth from Chicago that's a good
question oh thank you you can't go
through earth why well he'll also fair
enough salmon a nose Sam sorry buddy all
right Sam Jordan argh if usian Club
volcano erupted it'd be like no other
Devils cranky who could have written
this one you're the flash on treadmill
run Barry run as me I wrote that minder
guys this is what we Ya Sam's gonna make
a fool of himself doing this we want you
to turn this gif into an animated gif it
would be an enemy for you and swap out
the green screen for something real
silly well that would be the best
Christmas present for Sam cuz he's about
to be the flash like in the whole game
you know all of us would enjoy that gift
it just keeps giving all year round ok
Shane
shame shame shame oh how wonderful shame
does he shame does he well I guess
that'd be crazy if its mouth is open all
kinds of got in there is going fast
that's a bit better
hey thank you so much for watching this
week's episode of new Rockstar news I'm
your winner Maude Garrett I want to
thank the flash you managed to join us
on this episode sampling feelings and
flashes gives the flash shirt and I'll
say Eric Voss hi bye guys what a time
it's been no no we're not nor loser he's
just happy to be middle the road that's
it hey if you've watched this you get to
like and subscribe it share out your
friends give the gift that everyone
wants this Christmas the link to this
video you can also tweet at us at new
rock stars we always ask you guys to ask
us a question that we do in lightning
round and disappoint you without fail
well good we'll see you next week again
I'm your weena what Garrett thanks for
listening to me thanks for reading yeah
you got in there